you were probably too busy dancing
driving and having the time of your life
during Mamma Mia too to notice but if
you did try to make sense of mamma mias
timeline it might have made your head
spin
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to explain
five crazy things about mamma mias
timeline which make it all really rather
confusing and I'll also be announcing
the winners of my here we go again
giveaway the wonderful world of Mamma
Mia is not only full of beautiful
sparkling blue seas fabulously fun
spontaneous song and dance routines and
opportunities to live rent-free if you
happen to help the right horse but it
also seems that they've managed to
perfect the art of technological
time-travel we see Sofie and Bill's
mother using some pretty up-to-date
iphones and some rather recent tablet
models appear in harry's tokyo meeting
but mama mia too isn't actually set now
which means that tech wise the mama mia
universe is well ahead of its time
okay i'm going to run through mamma mias
timeline to show you what i mean
when mama mia was released in 2008 the
date the story was set in was rather
vague but little to tie it down to a
particular year but here we go again
changed that giving us some specific
dates for movie detectives to create a
timeline of the events in both films
Lilly James's prequel story reveals that
Donna graduated in 1979 after which she
hooked up with Sophie's three potential
fathers during the summer after
graduation which lines up roughly with
the months mentioned in Donna's diary in
the first film so Donna became pregnant
with Sophie during the summer of 1979
which allowing nine months for the
pregnancy means Sophie was born in 1980
we know that in the first film sophie is
20 years old she were more like me she
wouldn't be a 20
so given Sophie was born in 1980 the
first film must have been set in the
year 2000 as for here we go again that
set five years after the original movie
in 2005 we know that because when Ruby
says she wants to commit to being a
grandmother sophie accuses her of being
25 years too late and amanda seyfried
confirmed this five year gap between the
stories during press for the film the
problem with the tech in Mamma Mia too
is that it doesn't match this timeline
the first iPhones weren't released until
2007 and the care
actors in the movie are actually using
pretty up-to-date ones with Sophie's
iPhone looking like it's probably a
model from around 2013 onwards while the
2 in 1 laptop tablet used by the execs
in Harry's meeting is from a Microsoft
range that was only introduced in 2013
all of which means that while the Greek
island of Kalahari isn't exactly
Europe's answer to a candor somehow
they've still managed to nab themselves
some high-tech gadgets that weren't even
available at the time the movie set
another timeline problem pops up with
Donna's graduation in 1979 at New
College Oxford where according to Lily
James the idea was that Donna was the
first-ever female valedictorian but
while this scene certainly gets 10 out
of 10 for fun it gets far fewer points
for accuracy the reason being that while
New College Oxford was founded in 1379
they didn't admit the first female
undergraduates until 1979 and as
Oxford's academic year starts in October
it would have been impossible for Donna
to graduate in the summer of 1979 as
that would have been before any women
undergraduates had ever been admitted to
new college on top of that valedictorian
speeches and honours are typically a
North American tradition and not
something that happened previously at
Oxford I think the filmmakers decided to
go with the valedictorian speech for
Donna as they needed an excuse for her
to get up on stage and also wanted to
show as a trailblazer and the kind of
person who shattered conventions
writer-director old Parker told e.w that
to do that they needed to put on it in
the stuffiest possible surrounding and
then have her shake that up
Parker chose Oxford as he says it was
the most fabulously pompous place they
could find in a good way fabulously
learned and impressive so it was all the
funnier for Lily to rip off her costume
and go for it and Donna's age when she
graduates in 1979 creates another issue
with the timeline as she was probably
several years too young Andy Garcia who
plays Fernando Cienfuegos has said his
character could well be Donna's father
and the movie seems to imply it was
Fernando's love affair with Ruby which
led to Ruby becoming pregnant with Donna
in the film Sam Debose reveals that his
romance with Ruby took place in 1959 and
assuming that's when Donna was conceived
she would have been born in late 1959 or
1960 that would make Donna around 18
nineteen years old at the time of her
graduation in summer 1979 as
undergraduate courses in Oxford are
typically three to four years long Donna
must have started college when she was
only around 15 or so years old now it's
not unheard of for child prodigies to go
to college at a young age but as much as
we all love Donna that's never been part
of her story also as absolutely loads of
you have pointed out when it comes to
Donna's best friends Tania and Rosie the
timeline is rather fuzzy about who knew
who what and when in the first film it's
clearly news to Tanya and Rosie that
anyone other than Sam could have been
Sophie's dad remember I said it was Sam
Sam the architect who had to go home to
get married I'm not sure what it is
there were two other two other guys
around the same time and when Tanya and
Rosie see Bill in the original film we
don't get any sense I've ever met before
yes in here we go again we learned they
already met bill when they were young
and they even encouraged Donner to get
over Sam with him what's more Rosie even
had a big crush on young bill all of
which sounds like the kind of things
you'd remember when they crop up later
but maybe all that Greek Sun and ooze Oh
simply went to their heads and there's
also the puzzling case of Harry's
missing guitar and switched around diary
dates and if you'd like to know more
about that check out my video in the
card here or video description below we
already know that technology can travel
back from the future in the Mamamia
universe so it shouldn't be a surprise
that human beings can also time travel
in this absolutely fabulous world thanks
to eagle-eyed Twitter user Tom Zohar we
now know that this dancing waiter
traveled from 1979 to 2005 without ever
looking a single year older though he
did have time for a quick shave the
dancer in question is Justin Thomas who
showed up in both the Waterloo routine
in Paris with young Donna and Harry and
then again over 25 years later when sure
made her grand entrance on the island so
either share really can turn back time
or the dancer has a portrait of himself
hidden away like Dorian Gray and here's
a little bonus timeline craziness for
you given the sequel is set into
thousand and five there's no way the
grand reopening for the hotel belladonna
could have been on Saturday July the 7th
which is a date we see on Sophie's
invites because in 2005 July the 7th was
a Thursday now obviously when they shot
the first film they never planned on
making another one so they didn't worry
about how story decisions they made
might impact a sequel and his events in
the Mamma Mia stage musical took place
in 1999 the year the show opened in the
West End that's likely where the
filmmakers got inspiration for their
timeline for me there's far too much fun
to be had watching both the Mamma Mia
movies for these timeline issues to get
in the way
after all the Mamma Mia verse is all
about the joy and the music so the share
says in the sequel let's concentrate on
the here and now and on that note if
you'd like to check out ten amazing
details in Mamma Mia - that will make
you love the sequel even more then tap
on the card or the link in the video
description or at the end of this video
now what did you think of Mama Mia's
timeline issues and did you spot any
other inconsistencies in the movies
congratulations to all the winners of my
here we go again merch giveaway please
contact me or check your email if you've
registered it for details on how to
receive the prize tap left to watch five
crucial differences between the two
Mamma Mia movies or tap right for
another fun than a mere video thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers